you have to fight right away you like
get to County Jail yeah put your things
down you don't even get a chance to eat
you just walk out and empty stomachs so
it was this big skinhead dude and he's
got like the swastika right there and
you know it's meth and all that so he
walks up I think I got like my paperwork
like looking at what they're charging me
with like holy
and he just pushes it off the table and
he's like Punk check so we just found a
little blind spot in the bathroom and I
wrapped my knuckles with like toilet
paper because I didn't know I don't know
how to fight you know but I knew I just
had to
drop them and hit them as hard as I
could from the jump it was the only way
I was going to have a chance so we went
in there and we just faded for like a
minute yeah basically caught me four or
five times okay yeah it's not
necessarily about winning but it's about
showing you're not [__] exactly